THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
EXERCISE.
AND THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
BLOW IT.
JORGE RAMOS IS ANCHOR AT
UNIVISION NEWS AND UNIVISION
>> I NEVER IMAGINED I WOULD
BE ON FOX NEWS LISTENING TO
YOU CRITICIZING PRESIDENT
TRUMP ON IMMIGRATION.
THANKS FOR INVITING ME.
THE PRINCIPLE WHICH IS THAT
A COUNTRY HAS A RIGHT TO
DETERMINE WHO ENTERS IT AND
WHO GETS CITIZENSHIP, WHO
VOTES, WHO CHOOSES THE
GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S WHAT A COUNTRY IS AND
THAT AND YOU SEEM TO.
>> WHAT I ALSO AGREE, TUCKER
I THINK WE ALL AGREE WITH
THAT.
THEY'RE HERE BECAUSE OF US.
THEY ARE HARVESTING THE FOOD
THAT WE EAT.
THEY ARE BUILDING OUR HOMES.
THEY ARE TAKING CARE OF OUR
KIDS AND WE HAVE TO FIND A
SOLUTION AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP, SURPRISINGLY, I DON'T
TRUST HIM, I DON'T BELIEVE
HIM BUT SURPRISINGLY IN THIS
MEETING HE SAID HE WANTS
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
YOU AND I REMEMBER, THIS IS
THE YEAR 2,000 WHENEVER WE
SAY COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM THAT
MEANS LEGALIZING 11 MILLION
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY.
IF THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO DO
THAT, I'M ALL FOR IT
HOWEVER, I'M NOT SURE THAT
TOMORROW PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
GOING TO COME WITH A TWEET
OR WITH AN INTERVIEW AND
CHANGE AGAIN.
>> Tucker: LET ME STOP AND
CHALLENGE YOUR PREMISE WHICH
IS DEEPLY DISINGENUOUS.
IT'S SOMEHOW OUR FAULT
CORPORATELY ALL OF OUR FAULT
THAT 11 MILLION PEOPLE SNUCK
INTO THE COUNTRY.
>> THEY ARE HERE BECAUSE OF
US.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT TRUE.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF ME OR
MOST PEOPLE I KNOW.
IT'S BECAUSE A SMALL NUMBER
OF EMPLOYERS WANTED TO PAY
LESS FOR LABOR AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WANTED NEW
VOTERS.
I DIDN'T DO THAT AND THERE
IS NO REASON I SHOULD HAVE
CAME HERE ILLEGALLY.
WHY SHOULD I?
>> THEY ARE HERE BECAUSE OF
YOU AND ME.
IT'S SIMPLY A MATTER OF
SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
THEY ARE HERE SPLIMPLELY
BECAUSE THERE ARE JOBS FOR
THEM AND ALSO WE HAVE TO
ADMIT BECAUSE IN LATIN
AMERICA THEY MAKE MAYBE $5 A
DAY.
THEY CAN MAKE THAT EXACT
AMOUNT OF HERE IN A FEW
HOURS.
WE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THEM.
>> Tucker: SO BECAUSE THIS
IS A SUCCESSFUL COUNTRY.
>> YOU AND I ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THEM.
>> Tucker: BECAUSE WE HAVE
TAKEN THE TIME TO BUILD A
FUNCTIONING COUNTRY, CLEAN,
SAFE COUNTRY WITH WORKING
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND A
THRIVING ECONOMY, THEN WE
ARE SOMEHOW MORALLY REQUIRED
TO LET ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO
COME HERE COME AND WE CAN'T
>> NO.
BECAUSE EVERY TIME YOU GO TO
HELPING YOU.
THEY ARE WORKING FOR US.
>> Tucker: NO.
THEY ARE NOT WORKING FOR ME.
THEY ARE WORKING FOR
COMPANIES THAT WANTS TO PAY
LESS.
THAT'S WHY THEY HIRE THEM
AND OWNERS OF THOSE
COMPANIES MAKE A LOT OF
SUPPORT THEM LIVING HERE.
>> JUST FOR A WHILE BUT FOR
INSTANCE, THE NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES RECENTLY
CONDUCTED A STUDY AND THEY
CONCLUDED THAT ALL
IMMIGRANTS IN THIS COUNTRY
THEY CONTRIBUTE MORE THAN
AND NOT ONLY THAT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S AN ABSURD
NUMBER.
>> YOU CAN LAUGH ABOUT THAT.
>> Tucker: I'M LAUGHING
BECAUSE I KNOW A LOT ABOUT
THE SUBJECT AND THAT'S A
THE NATIONAL ACADEMY OF
SCIENTISTS BUT I'M SORRY I
ECONOMY.
>> Tucker: RATHER THAN THROW
AROUND FAKE NUMBERS, I WOULD
RATHER GET TO THE PRINCIPLE
THOUGH YOU MAKE A FAIR POINT
WHICH IS SUPPLY AND DEMAND
IS DRIVING THIS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
HIRE ILLEGALLY FOR SURE.
WHY SHOULD AMERICAN CITIZENS
WHO BY AND LARGE ARE NOT
A COUNTRY WHERE PEOPLE WHO
SNEAK IN ILLEGALLY GET TO
VOTE AND DETERMINE WHO RUNS
THEIR GOVERNMENT?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND?
NO OTHER COUNTRY WOULD ALLOW
THAT.
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM, IF IT'S TRUE WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PROPOSING
AND I DON'T THINK HE IS
TELLING THE TRUTH OR THAT HE
EVEN UNDERSTANDS WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE, AND THEN
THEY MIGHT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY EVENTUALLY IN
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE AT THIS
POINT.
WE ARE NOT EVEN DISCUSSING
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
>> Tucker: IT'S AN ISSUE FOR
ME AND AMERICAN CITIZENS I
COUNTRY.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS IF YOU
COME HERE ILLEGALLY YOU ARE
DEMANDING PEOPLE COME HERE
ILLEGALLY HAVE THE RIGHT TO
BE HERE LEGALLY AND GET
CITIZENSHIP.
WHY SHOULD THOSE PEOPLE BE
ALLOWED TO BRING THEIR
RELATIVES FROM A FOREIGN
COUNTRY?
NOW EVERYBODY IS USING THE
TERM CHAIN MIGRATION.
>> Tucker: MAJORITY OF
IMMIGRATION IS CHAIN
MIGRATION.
IT'S NOT A SMALL THING.
>> ACTUALLY IT'S CALLED
FAMILY REYIEWN IF I TITION
FEI OCCASION.
IT'S CALLED THE SAME THING.
>> DO YOU ENJOY SPENDING
TIME WITH YOUR FAMILY,
TUCKER?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: THIS IS TOO
SERIOUS A MATTER WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THEORETICAL
DEBATES.
LET ME ASK YOU, WHY SHOULD
>> IMMIGRANTS DO TOO.
THEY DO ENJOY SPENDING TIME
WITH THEIR FAMILIES.
SINCE 165, INSPIRED BY JFK,
BEFORE HE DIED.
SINCE 1965, THE POLICY THAT
WE HAVE HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES FAVORS FAMILY
REUNIFICATION AND BRING IN
THOSE WHO HAVE SPECIAL
TALENTS TO THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: YOU BUT YOU ARE
RECIPIENTS HAVE SPECIAL
TALENTS.
THAT.
I KNOW IT'S THE POLICY.
THAT'S THE QUESTION?
>> BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A
WISE POLICY.
JUST SEE THE NUMBER OF CEOS,
IMMIGRANTS, WHO ARE LEADING
MAJOR COMPANIES IN THIS
COUNTRY.
I THINK WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
USES THE TERM CHAIN
MIGRATION, THOSE ARE CODE
WORDS.
IS HE REALLY SAYING, YOU
KNOW, I DON'T WANT MORE
IMMIGRANTS FROM ASIA OR
LATINO AMERICA COMING FROM
IT -- THOSE ARE THE WORDS
THAT I TAKE FROM PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU ARE
BIG GOT TRI WHICH IS A
LITTLE MUCH, ACTUALLY,
CONSIDERING YOU ARE
DEMANDING THAT AMERICANS WHO
WERE BORN HERE, LET IN
PEOPLE WHO SNUCK IN
ILLEGALLY AND ALL THEIR
FAMILY AND IF THEY SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT IT THEY ARE
RACIST.
>> CHAIN MIGRATION.
>> Tucker: I GET THE GAME
ACTUALLY AND I'M SICK OF IT.
>> OR FAMILY REUNIFICATION.
MATTER.
IT'S THE SAME.
>> THAT'S THE LAW OF THE
LAND.
>> Tucker: HOW WOULD YOU
FEEL IF THE UNITED STATES
EXPORTED THE POOREST 10% OF
POPULATION TO MEXICO,
COMPLETELY CHANGED THE MIX
OF MEXICO, THE POLITICS OF
MEXICO AND UNDERCUT THE
WABLETION OF MEXICAN
CITIZENS AND IF ANYONE
COMPLAINED ABOUT IT SAY YOU
ARE JUST A RACIST.
WOULD YOU THINK THAT WAS
KIND OF A STICK-UP?
>> I UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN MEXICO AND IT'S
TERRIBLE WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
MEXICO.
I CANNOT DEFEND AND I DO NOT
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
WAS THAT YOUR QUESTION?
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT THE
QUESTION BUT WE ARE OUT OF
TIME SADLY BUT I KNOW WE